(happy music)
- [Group Voiceover] Dead Kevin
- You guys are just
a bunch of assholes,
I put up with this
shit long enough.
You haven't paid
rent in four months
You broke down your
own door 'cause
you locked yourself out again.
You stole a neighbors
dog, it had a collar!
- We said sorry about that
- This is the last straw,
get me the money by
tomorrow or you're evicted!
- He said evicted.
- What does that mean?
- Kicked out of the house.
- Ooh.
- You don't know
what evicted means?
- I do now.
- What are we gonna do?
- Only one thing we can do.
- I don't like this.
- It's fine we're gonna be fine.
- Are we really
doing this right now?
- Yes we're really
doing this right now,
we don't have a choice, alright?
- Alright.
- Okay?
You bring your masks?
- [Man In Gray Jacket] Yeah
- [Blonde man] Yeah
- [Guy With Curly
Hair] Let's do this.
What are you wearing?
What the?
What is this?
- You said panties.
- I said, Jack pantyhose.
- What is the difference
between panties and pantyhose?
- Pantyhose-
- Those are fishnets, you
can see your whole face.
- This is perfect
- Who gives a shit,
no one recognizes us.
- Okay, we're fine
- Are we doing this?
we're fine, okay yes, let's go!
Are you ready?
- What is that, what are
you gonna do with that?
- I'm just gonna hit
some stuff around.
- We should just
give 'em a note.
Give them a note
- This is our time.
We're not gonna give any note,
this is our time, let's go
Are we in?
- Alright
- Okay
- [Fishnet] One,
- [Everyone] Two, Three!
- No we can't do
this, this is not us
- This is ridiculous,
we're so stupid.
- What are we doing man?
- What are we doing?
- We're gonna go to
jail if we do this.
- For what, for what?
For money?
- That was close
- That was shit
- We're gonna be fine
- That was close.
- We're gonna be fine.
- It's gonna work out,
it always works out
- Let's just, let's go
- we're gonna be fine
back home, it's gonna be fine
- We're gonna be fine.
We're gonna be fine!
- Wow.
- (Yelling) Shoes are the
most important accessory
of the homeless lifestyle!
This is day one stuff, boys!
(mumbling)
- Okay sir,
- What is your problem?
You don't fucking work hard!
You aint' out gettin'
change with your instrument
where's your sign?
- Okay can you just-
Where's your funny story?
- Just give us-
Where's your hook gone?
- Just one minute-
- You ain't got nothing!
- Why are you getting so angry?
- You know what's going on!
Where's my damn rainbow?
- I don't know what that-
- Look at you, you
too damn pretty,
should be a prostitute!
Hold on a second.
(normal volume) Hello?
Oh hi mom, I am in the middle
of something right now.
(yelling) Shut up while
I'm talking on the phone!
- Sir we weren't-
- What you doing
with that red bowl?
Give me that bowl, give
me that God damn bowl
it's my bowl now.
- Hey-
I like chips.
- [White Tank] But
if we could just.
- [Flannel] Okay.
- Apparently you didn't
like and subscribe enough.
- Is this the end of Dead Kevin?
- Subscribe to our
YouTube page and find out.
And leave a comment about
an interaction you've had
with a homeless person recently.
- Hey there's a pigeon in here
- Don't eat it
- Sweet
- Don't eat it.